in your addiction not that i knew you
and your addiction but i get the sense
that in your addiction that you were
just a perfectly sweet lovable guy he
was just really sick yeah yeah yeah i
feel like i was the same except for
you know the uh
being desperate i feel like you know the
bummer was for me it was like waking up
and my you know that thought of just
what am i gonna do today how am i
getting money right how am i gonna score
even if i have a lot of money do it
right now do i do i know anybody or do i
want to drive down to a bad area and
risk it and that was you know that was
the for me the struggle and then so
again but yeah i don't feel like i ever
luckily
things always seem to work out to where
i never did anything too foolish like
stealing or robbing or anything crazy
luckily um
you know it always sort of somehow
worked out
um
again but i mean link maybe because
again sometimes people would be like bro
we want you to get help uh but i wanted
to do something stupid so there's 40
bucks you know or whatever
that's so funny it reminds me of time i
had a drug dealer
meet up with me right and and he looked
at me and i was trying to get an eight
ball of cocaine and he looked at me and
he's like dude i can't i can't
i can't give this to you unless you
[ __ ] eat something dude and the drug
dealer like drove me
to a place and and like eat something
like he drove me to a [ __ ] frozen
yogurt shop and and made me eat a thing
of frozen yogurt and then he gave me the
eight balls again
he's got a few more bites there come on
now
finish your greens finish
as far as running from cops um god this
was back in 1994 i was i was following
the grateful dead around and i was i'd
show up at the show with like five bucks
and i would buy like three hits fasted
and then sell each of them for five
bucks and i had 15 bucks and i would
like buy something else it was just this
like low-grade drug hustle but there was
one point at uh i want to say like
meadowland stadium in new jersey towards
the end of the tour
and i had a bunch of acid on me
and uh and i was doing a drug deal and i
[ __ ] handed this guy
some acid and he gave me some money
and then i turned my head and there's
two [ __ ] cops just watch that happen
they're like [ __ ] hey and i swear
i've never ran so [ __ ] fast
in my life i tried fully [ __ ] through
the parking lot these cops gave chase
and i'm through the parking lot and
[ __ ] ran and here's the crazier say
thank god i got away were you thinking
because i i had i did at that point acid
wouldn't do [ __ ] to me because you know
you take acid every day it just stops
working like um
yeah it lingers too long yeah it's like
but it's it's also like acid as far as
like the laws go it falls into like a
really [ __ ] yeah you're [ __ ] you're
selling acid like you're going to prison
for a long time you know like that was
the thing about the grateful dead tour
and with all the people following it is
that the grateful dead tour left just in
its wake
just all kinds of people in prison for
decades
for selling acid so like you know like
you said if if that cop didn't get into
that car it would have changed your life
like i mean [ __ ] dude like
if i hadn't have been so nimble and so
fast
i would have really had a [ __ ]
problem i would have been in prison for
a [ __ ] long time yeah yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude